[Music]
the bio near when it comes to the way
you train are you more of a Goku or are
you more of a Vegeta now this might
sound like a nerdy topic even for the
bioner but I think that a lot of people
find themselves inspired by Dragon Ball
to some extent and for many of us it's
what got us into training or at least it
was a factor in getting us into training
in the first place
and if you're someone who's into your
training then you're going to recognize
a lot of truths in Dragon Ball that you
can relate to and one of these is the
dichotomy between your Goku types and
your Vegeta types so what am I talking
about and which type are you so you have
your Goku these are the people who train
for its own sake they love training they
love taking on stronger opponents for
the sake of it then you have your
vegetas and these are the types who
train because they have a chip on their
shoulder something to prove they want to
be the best they're comparing themselves
to others and they're constantly pushing
them themselves for that reason and I
think by better understanding this
dichotomy and by assessing what
motivates our own training we can
actually better understand where we're
coming from and maybe help ourselves to
get greater gains far be it for me to
say that one approach to training one
motivation for training is better than
another but I will suggest that for the
vast majority of people perhaps that
training more like Goku is actually
going to be better and this is what we
see in the anime where Goku is
constantly beating Vegeta in a seemingly
effortless way and the reason for this
is that while it's great to have an
intense willpower to forward yourself
through hard work and determination to
grind towards Victory it's also really
hard work and eventually for many of us
we're going to fall off somewhere if
it's always an effort to get to the gym
if you're always pushing yourself to the
Limit if you're always making yourself
train harder and harder then at some
point something's going to snap and even
if it doesn't you're going to have an
off day where you just don't have the
motivation or the energy to train as
hard as as you might like on the other
hand if you're someone who trains for
the love of training if you find it
intrinsically motivating if it's play to
you then it's
easy you know that attitude of enjoying
the journey it doesn't just apply to
training it can apply to anything from
business to productivity and to your
diet of course and that's why I'm very
pleased to introduce today's sponsor
magic spoon so magic spoon is a
wholesome cial that ticks a lot of boxes
for a lot of people it contains no sugar
it has no artificial ingredients and
it's high in protein and all this stuff
makes it easier for you to eat well and
meet your goals while at the same time
enjoying yourself because magic spoon
tastes and looks just like the cereal
you probably enjoyed eating as a kid in
front of cartoons for me simply swapping
out foods for other Alternatives is one
of the simplest ways to meet my macros
to make sure I'm getting enough protein
and not consuming too much sugar or too
many calories my favorite flavor is the
fruity one but they make a whole bunch
and they're actually all really tasty
click the link below to grab a variety
pack and to try it today and be sure to
use the promo code super functional at a
checkout to get $5 off of any order or
go to
magicpx spoon is so confident in their
product that it's backed with a 100%
happiness guarantee that means that if
you don't like it for whatever reason
they'll refund your money no questions
asked so click the link below and use
the promo code superfunctional for $5
off or go to
magicpedia seriously I have a lot of fun
and I really go easy on myself I'm not
pushing myself all the time far from IT
thing is that doesn't actually matter
and the reason for that is that I don't
have to push myself I don't have to be
disciplined to keep training because I
love it see I've also had a lot of
achievements when it comes to playing
video games for example I was actually
in a magazine for the best time running
around one of the tracks in Sonic car
backwards that's right and yet very few
people ever say Adam I'm so proud of you
for getting the best time ever in that
magazine running around a track in Sonic
car backwards likewise if I spend two
hours playing a computer game no one's
going to say wow he's disciplined and
it's the same for me because if I have
free time I have a day off and I can do
whatever I want to do no pressure then
yeah playing computer games is one of
the things I'm going to do and then the
other thing I'm going to do is I'm going
to go to the gym because I love it that
much and so it's not a chore for me to
train likewise I love making content
like it's impulsive for me I'll sit
there in the evening is just editing
videos together whilst we're watching TV
I'm second screening it and I'll write
into the evening cuz I have ideas and I
really want to write them down so I'm
not pushing myself I'm not forcing
myself to work or to work out I'm just
doing it because I love it so I
shouldn't really get any credit as
someone who's really working hard and
grinding because I'm not grinding and
I'm really undisciplined with loads of
other stuff like my rumors untidy I
never open my post you know and I think
a lot of people are like this a lot of
people we think are like super
disciplined actually they just love what
they do and so it's easy to stay
disciplined it doesn't make more sense
to be like that rather than try and
force yourself and push yourself every
day and every day it's a battle now I
will say that there is something to be
said for romanticizing the battle like I
quite enjoy those days where I'm feeling
beat up and tired and I don't want to
train then I find the determination to
train anyways but the only reason I like
doing that is because I'm essentially
pretending to be Vegeta you know I'm I'm
enjoying the challenge there it's still
me just nerding
out
curse those other YouTubers and their
millions of subscribers what do they
have that I don't Perfect Clean
handstand push-ups chiseled ABS well
they'll see with each subscriber a new
indignation well no
more it is my destiny heed my words I
will rise to the top I will train as no
one has ever trained before and I will
become the greatest Fitness YouTuber in
the entire
universe are you proud of me now Mommy
and if you're constantly comparing
yourself to other people if you're
constantly trying to push yourself
harder and you're not satisfied with the
results this isn't great for your
mentality either even if you get the
progress you want even if you build like
the perfect physique and smash through
your PRS you're going to be kind of
miserable doing it now obviously it's
great for me to say this but if you're
not someone who naturally enjoys
training then you're not just going to
magically wake up and now you love
training so what can we do in this
situation well one thing to do is to
find a kind of training that you do more
naturally enjoy Don't force yourself to
go to the gym I think a lot of us think
we have to go to the gym to be in shape
and that's not true at all obviously you
can train from home what I'm more
talking about is that you can do Sports
you can do rock climbing you can do
swimming you can do martial arts all
these are great ways to get fit you can
do virtual reality training likewise if
you like your training but there's a
move in there that you really hate like
I don't really like squats and deadlifts
I just don't really do them that often I
do them sometimes cuz I want the results
I love kettle bell swings and that's a
great alternative to the deadlift so
find something that you enjoy doing
instead and I'm not saying we should
never have any willpower or never force
ourselves to do anything we don't want
but if you do have to do something you
don't want then at least try and find a
way to make it fun and interesting I
think a lot of people think we have to
do the hard work to get the results but
if you can get the results without doing
horrible grinding work then why wouldn't
you take the easier path the more
enjoyable path you might even take
longer to get there but at least you
have fun along the way and you're far
far more likely to stick at it to me
there's no inherent value in hard work
it's good to be able to work hard if it
means that benefits other people
benefits yourself but the hard work
itself there's no inherent value in that
don't glorify hard work and to me that's
more badass to me characters like Goku
and Sonic are more badass than
characters like say The Punisher because
to me it's cooler to win with a smile
than it is with a Grimace you're with a
smile and it's like you didn't even
break a sweat and before I go I will
just say there is an argument to be made
for a third type of gymgo that being the
piccolo and the piccolo is someone who's
cool and detached whose ego isn't at all
involved in the training and they just
set themselves a plan stick to it and
get the results I know people like that
and that works really well too if you're
that kind of person then kudos to you
far more disciplined and organized than
I am let me know in the comments down
below which type you are or if there's
any that I might have missed maybe
you're a yamer who knows either way
thank you so much for watching guys and
I'll see you next
time bye for now